Before we say goodbye,
we'd like to play a quick round of...
Drewth or Dare.
(audience cheering)
Oh.
Okay, Audrey Han?
Yeah.
Hi, Audrey.
Hi, Drew, hi, Ross.
I'm so excited to be here and to meet you guys in person.
You are so pretty with like the best style.
Aw, thank you so much.
These little cheery earrings.
Oh my, that's the cherry on top of the sundae right there.
That's cute, mhmm.
All right, what's it gonna be a Drewth or a dare?
It's gonna be a Drewth.
Okay.
So what's one thing that you would love to do
if there were zero consequences?
Oh.
Mine's so boring.
Do you wanna know truly what it is?
It's really the honest truth.
Is I would eat like all the pizza I could.
Because I broke up with pizza.
It was a great thing while it lasted,
but I am not doing it anymore.
And I just haven't eaten it in so long,
'cause the consequences.
I'm allergic to it, it makes my body swell.
You understand?
I mean, do you guys know the movie "Defending Your Life"?
It's an Albert Brooks movie.
Yes.
It's so meaningful.
It's just one of my favorite all-time movies.
And in it when they go into the, you know, purgatory,
basically you get to eat anything you want
without gaining any weight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's the dream.
Yeah, so not to be boring, but I might piggyback on you.
Yes, Barrymore!
And if I could eat without consequence,
that's all I want.
Yeah,
that would be the dream.
Because my metabolism
is that of a sloth on a very heavy dose of Valium.
Yeah, mhmm.
And it's just that sloth is like asleep at the switch.
I eat one donut, and I've got like a giant donut
popping out of my skin.
If I smell a cheese puff, 10 pounds.
You understand?
Yes, totally!
I am like a human pendulum.
So eating without consequence
would be everything.
Everything.
You'd eat pizza first?
Yeah.
I know you can guess my first food.
Mac and cheese.
Macaroni and cheese.
Great question.
Great question, Audrey!
Thank you!
Now I have something to dream about.
(upbeat music)